billboards and other outdoor advertising
can often be an eyesore but one company
has found a way to blend creativity with
commerce they put up custom murals one
hand-painted stroke at a time delivering
a client's message while also
beautifying a neighborhood Don Dahler
has the story in cities around the
country street art attracts those
looking for the perfect selfie backdrop
they are grand and intricate colorful
and sometimes controversial and
increasingly they're selling something
you don't often think of advertising as
art you you don't and and I think what's
unique about you know what we do is that
it's art first right Paul Lynde all is
the co-founder of colossal media his
Brooklyn based company may be the
largest hand-painted advertisement firm
in the US with clients including Samsung
Delta Comedy Central and Nintendo
[Applause]
what is the allure to these companies
that are hiring you to do these I think
the allure is that they get access to
these neighborhoods that we live in and
that we work and we really know about
Brooklyn you know we really know about
the arts district in Los Angeles so I
think that if you're a brand it's about
you know getting connected it's about
getting people's attention you know we
do that in a real truthful way Lyndall
and his crew have been getting people's
attention since 2004 it took a while to
change the perception of hand-painted
ads as outdated and time-consuming and
worth the additional cost but now
colossal media leases a hundred and
twenty walls in various cities and the
company raked in twenty four million
dollars in sales last year how much does
social media play in this now with
social media and being able to put out a
message somebody across the world might
be able to see you know like the work
that you've done Linda says it's
important for people to be able to see
the painstaking process that leads to
the final product outdoor art isn't easy
to do we were working through the bomb
cyclone we just pushed through that
entire thing we put something up on
social media that showed the guys
banging away while the the wind was
rushing by 60 miles an hour what's going
on in here so this is the room where
we're mixing all of our colors every job
that we do we have to take the artwork
and literally dissect it so we find
places on the artwork and isolate colors
but at the end of the day when we walk
away and we leave like the result needs
to look like a banner like it shouldn't
you shouldn't be able to tell that it's
painted right it's got to be as good if
not better murals can be a big draw for
tourists like in Miami's Wynwood Arts
District where art breathed new life
into a dying neighborhood as the
neighborhood grows you'll be able to see
pieces like this Goldman properties CEO
Jessica Goldman schrab Nick curates the
street art museum to me it's it's a pure
expression of creativity to be able to
do what these artists do in 2009 she and
her late father Toni Goldman opened the
Wynwood Walls transforming concrete into
canvas and blight
into light we have from no visitors to
over a million visitors a year
coming through the Wynwood Walls you
hear every language to noise and so that
to me is what makes for a really vibrant
beautiful neighborhood and I think the
Wynwood Walls has done a beautiful job
of democratizing the world of art and
making it accessible to everybody with
an estimated 44 murals inside these
walls schrab nick says this area has the
highest concentration of street art in
the country this street art created a
tourist industry
it created retail it created a
neighborhood it's pretty extraordinary
how one idea can have effects around the
world and on so many levels and I think
we're just seeing the beginning I think
you're gonna see so much more beautiful
artwork so much more public art so much
more art integrated into brands and
products and you know why not just makes
life so much more exciting and
interesting and for once starving
artists like Paul Lynde all it makes for
good business most artists I know have
to have a second job uh-huh how are
these guys doing well you know to me I
found something that was it was really
important and I really fell in love with
it I wanted to build some sort of like
sustainability around that and I wanted
to know like where I was gonna be at
when I woke up the next day and so it
was make a living yeah yeah I wanted to
make a living and when we started the
company you know that was the objective
and I thought to myself if I can do this
myself for the rest of my life I'll be
really lucky if you look at the company
now and we've got 401 k plans
everybody's got every kind of dental
plan you're going we're a corporate as
you wouldn't believe it's not about me
anymore there's 80 people with families
now that have their own reasons for
being at colossal and it's become
something in its own self and that I
think is worth fighting for for CBS this
morning Saturday Don Dahler New York